TRANSPARENT, THEY ARE GETTING
OUT IN FRONT, OR IS THIS
SOMETHING ELSE YOU SEE?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS PROBABLY --
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE IS
PROBABLY VERY ANGRY AT ITSELF
FOR HAVING MISHANDLED THIS
BECAUSE WHEN THE MAR-A-LAGO
MATERIALS BECAME SO POLITICALLY
SIGNIFICANT, THAT SHOULD HAVE
SPARKED AN INTEREST ON THE PART
OF THE PRESIDENT IN WHAT MIGHT
HAVE BECOME INTERFILED IN HIS
VICE PRESIDENTIAL MATERIALS.
UNDER OUR CURRENT SYSTEM --
>> HOW DO WE KNOW THAT'S NOT
WHAT THIS IS?
I MEAN, IF THE DISCOVERY WAS IN
NOVEMBER, THE FIRST DISCOVERY IN
NOVEMBER, MIGHT THAT BE TRYING
TO BE HYPERVIGILANT, GOING
THROUGH MATERIALS, SEARCHING OLD
OFFICES, AND LO AND BEHOLD, HERE
WE ARE?
YES OR NO ON THAT?
>> THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES WENT TO
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TEAM TO
REQUEST MATERIALS THAT WERE
CLEARLY NOT IN WASHINGTON BUT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN MAY OF 2021.
AND I WOULD BE SHOCKED IF THE
WHITE HOUSE DIDN'T KNOW
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT.
I THINK THE WHITE HOUSE JUST
SHOULD HAVE DONE THIS A LITTLE
SOONER, BECAUSE AS PAULA
MENTIONED, THE DRIP, DRIP, DRIP
IS PROBLEMATIC FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
>> YEAH.
>> WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT A
HUGE NUMBER OF DOCUMENTS, BUT,
LOOK, AS A FORMER DIRECTOR OF A
PRESIDENTIAL LIBRARY, THE PUBLIC
OWNS THOSE DOCUMENTS.
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
NATIONAL SECURITY MATERIALS, THE
PUBLIC HAS A RIGHT TO KNOW THOSE
MATERIALS ARE UNDER CONTROL.
IT'S NOT A LARGE COLLECTION, BUT
IT'S WORRISOME THAT THIS
COLLECTION -- THAT IT TOOK THE
WHITE HOUSE THIS LONG TO TRACK
DOWN THESE MATERIALS.
I CAN UNDERSTAND -- I CAN
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY FOUND THEIR
WAY INTO THE VICE PRESIDENT'S
PAPERS.
THE AMOUNT OF DOCUMENTS THAT GET
MOVED AT THE END OF AN
ADMINISTRATION ARE HUGE.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND VICE PRESIDENTS AND
PRESIDENTS ARE ALLOWED TO KEEP
THEIR PERSONAL MATERIALS.
IT'S ALWAYS POSSIBLE THAT
INTERFILED WITH THOSE PERSONAL
MATERIALS WILL BE STUFF THEY
SHOULDN'T BE BRINGING.
BUT THERE'S TIME TO FIND THAT
MATERIAL, AND IN THIS CASE, THE
WHITE HOUSE, GIVEN HOW SENSITIVE
THIS ISSUE IS NOW, JUST DIDN'T
LOOK FOR THEM QUICKLY ENOUGH,
I'M AFRAID.
>> SO THAT'S WHERE THIS IS A
LITTLE CONFUSE ORGANIZE MAYBE A
LOT CONFUSING.
PERHAPS YOU CAN HELP US
UNDERSTAND THIS.
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES WILL
MAINTAIN THE LIBRARY OF THINGS
FOR THE WHITE HOUSE,
PARTICULARLY AS ONE WHITE HOUSE
TRANSITIONS TO ANOTHER.
SO THEY KNOW THEY HAVE A LOG.
THEY KNOW ALMOST IMMEDIATELY
WHAT SHOULD BE, YOU KNOW, IN THE
INVENTORY, WHEREAS FOR THE VICE
PRESIDENT, APPARENTLY -- YOU'RE
NODDING YOUR HEAD NO.
OKAY.
LET ME FINISH THE QUESTION.
SO THE VICE PRESIDENT'S OFFICE,
THERE ARE AIDES INVOLVED, EXCUSE
ME, AIDES INVOLVED AS OPPOSED TO
AN ARCHIVE KNOWING ABOUT THE
LIBRARY OF CONTENT.
IS THAT WHERE THE DIFFERENCES
ARE HERE, THAT HE WAS THE VICE
PRESIDENT AND IT TAKES TIME TO
DO INVENTORY?
NO.
OKAY.
HELP ME OUT.
>> THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES IS
UNDERFUNDED.
THERE ISN'T A LOG OF MATERIALS
FOR EITHER THE PRESIDENT OR THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
IT DOESN'T EXIST.
IT TAKES YEARS TO PROCESS THESE
MATERIALS.
THERE ARE STILL MATERIALS FROM
THE NIXON PRESIDENCY THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN PROCESSED.
THEY ARE UNDER CONTROL, WHERE
NECESSARY THEY'RE IN A VAULT,
BUT THEY STILL HAVEN'T BEEN
PROCESSED.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A PRESIDENCY
FROM THE 1970s.
SO THERE IS NO LAW.
BUT THERE ARE AREAS OF THE WHITE
HOUSE WHERE DOCUMENTS ARE KEPT.
AND THOSE MATERIALS ARE BOXED
AND THEY ARE MOVED BOTH FOR THE
PRESIDENT AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
THE CHALLENGE IS WHAT HAPPENS TO
THE MATERIALS AFTER THEY GO TO
THE PRIVATE RESIDENCES OF A
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT AND FORMER
PRESIDENT.
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES DOESN'T
HAVE THE FUNDING TO GO TO THOSE
PRIVATE RESIDENCES AND
DOUBLE-CHECK THAT THERE AREN'T
MATERIALS THAT BELONG TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
INTERFILED WITH THE PRIVATE
MATERIALS.
THAT'S A FLAW IN T